remember the 2005 coming of age
superhero movie sky high
you won't believe which actor went on to
become an academy award winner keep
watching to get the dirt on the entire
cast
michael and guarano starred in sky high
as will stronghold the son of legendary
heroes the commander and jet stream
whose late blooming powers land him on
the sidekick track at his new super
school
ann garano was only 18 when sky high
first debuted but by that point he'd
already made over half a dozen tv
appearances and landed in several film
roles including a spot in cameron
crowe's music themed classic almost
famous sky high was just the beginning
of ann garano's film career over the
next decade he appeared in more than a
dozen films from the forbidden kingdom
to the stanford prison experiment he
also kept up an impressive television
career with recurring roles in the nick
24 will and grace and i'm dying up here
these days the 33 year old can currently
be seen as a recurring cast member in
the hit nbc drama this is us
danielle panabaker landed the part of
plant-loving layla in sky high her
feature film debut just a few years into
her acting career after the film's
release she spent the rest of the 2000s
appearing in films like yours mine and
hours and the 2009 reboot of friday the
13th
the early 2010s saw panna baker in a
number of tv series most notably
necessary roughness and fx's western
themed justified these days the 34 year
old panabaker is best known for her work
in the cw's aeroverse shows as caitlyn
snow and her supervillain alter ego
killer frost she first appeared in the
role as a guest star in the second
season of arrow but when cw created the
spin-off show the flash pannabaker
joined as a main cast member since then
she's appeared in multiple episodes of
other arrowverse shows like supergirl
and dc legends of tomorrow panabaker has
been vocal about her desire to return to
the world of sky high in 2019 she told
the international business times that
she would be quote a thousand percent
interested in participating in a sequel
she went on to say i'd like to think
that maybe they're teachers at sky high
because it's been long enough that they
could go back and teach
there aren't any solid plans for a
sequel so far but the door certainly
remains open
dj daniels had a prolific career as a
child actor he got his start on nbc's in
the house with ll cool j and had a
starring role on the hugelys from
1998-2002
sky high was daniel's first and only
film role his character ethan was part
of a group of sidekicks at the core of
the film and he finds a way to help save
the day despite his seemingly useless
ability to turn himself into a puddle of
goo despite his impressive and hilarious
performance daniel struggled to find
more work as he got older in an extended
2021 interview with vlad tv alongside
his former co-star dl hewgley daniels
opened up about his struggles with
acting fans were shocked to see that
over the years daniels had covered his
face with several tattoos a decision he
claimed to have made partially in
response to his lagging acting career
daniels also talked about how his career
was further derailed when he was
arrested on suspicion of murder in 2012.
it didn't take long for daniels to be
acquitted but the experience left an
impression on him nonetheless nowadays
daniels is pursuing a rap career but he
says that he's always open to returning
to acting
few actors from sky high have kept as
busy as nicolas braun who was just 17
when the film first released
braun told buzzfeed that he was with two
of his friends when he got the call that
he'd landed the role of zach in sky high
and that he couldn't contain his
excitement i screamed and yelled i still
feel that way though when i get apart if
that's the case braun has spent a good
amount of time yelling and screaming
after sky high braun spent a handful of
years bouncing between television shows
before landing a recurring role on 10
things i hate about you from there he
turned his attention to the big screen
for films like the stanford prison
experiment with fellow sky high alum
michael anne garano how to be single and
the perks of being a wallflower
brawn has kept just as busy in recent
years starring in two major films zola
and the big ugly in 2020 alone however
braun truly broke into the mainstream as
fan favorite character cousin greg in
hbo's succession as for what's to come
in bronze still young career you have to
wait and see like everybody else
but it's awesome man it's awesome
who could forget magenta the
shapeshifter that can only become a
guinea pig kelly vitz's character in sky
high had one of the most memorable
powers and definitely the most memorable
hairstyle magenta was put on the
sidekick track with the film's other
protagonists and she helped prove that
anyone no matter their powers has the
ability to be a hero vitz had a
short-lived acting career that began in
2002 when she made a one-line appearance
on the disney channel show lizzie
mcguire her next role was in sky high
and after that she landed roles in the
horror film simon says eye of the
dolphin nancy drew and teenius her final
film role was as ails gilmore in the
2010 film leone
that same year vitz graduated from the
university of california berkeley with a
degree in public health leaving the film
industry to pursue other career goals
steven strait was fresh out of high
school and just 18 years old when he
joined the cast of sky high as the aptly
named warren peace
sky high was straight's first feature
film and only his second professional
acting credit after a guest appearance
on third watch in 2001.
straight followed up the role with the
run of feature films over the next five
years which included the covenant
undiscovered 10 000 bc stop loss and
city island since 2015 straight has
starred in the sci-fi amazon prime
series the expanse as the brave starship
captain jim holden
in a december 2020 interview with geeks
of color strait was asked if he'd ever
consider reprising his role as war and
peace if disney revived sky high in some
way straight said that he's absolutely
open to the idea adding i loved that
experience and they're awesome people
malika hawk started acting in
commercials and tv shows at a young age
by the early 2000s she was used to the
grind of auditions and faceless casting
directors so much that when she and her
twin sister khadijah auditioned for sky
high they didn't even realize it was a
feature film
she told e online we actually thought
the movie was going to go straight to
the disney channel and out of all of
those options we felt so blessed and
overwhelmed to learn that sky high was
going to be our first film huck has
starred in a few more feature films in
the year since sky high most recently
she appeared in the 2016 film definitely
divorcing however hawke is best known
for her recurring role in the reality tv
series keeping up with the kardashians
she's been part of the show since season
2 and she was a main cast member on the
spin-off series dash dolls
khadija hawk mcrae's big break also came
when she was cast in sky high and her
career since has had a similar
trajectory to her sisters as well just
one year later the two went on to star
in the film atl
mccrae's last scripted acting role was
in an episode of kevin hart's real
husbands of hollywood in 2013 but like
her sister she was featured on keeping
up with the kardashians and co-starred
on dash dolls in 2010 she married nfl
defensive end bobby mcrae and in a
january 2021 instagram post the pair
announced a new addition to their family
jake sandvig was only 19 when sky high
arrived in theaters and it marked his
second feature film his first the story
of us starred bruce willis and michelle
pfeiffer and it came out when sandvik
was just 13 years old despite making
appearances in a few tv episodes in the
meantime it was after sky high that his
acting career really started to heat up
sandvik had recurring roles on 20 good
years and cracking up
his next major film role came in 2010's
easy a and a year later he wrote and
starred in the film a bag of hammers
after that sandvik returned to
television moving from weeds to csi to
usa's rush
his most recent roles were in 2017 when
he appeared in bridal boot camp and
hometown hero on the hallmark channel
will harris followed up his role as
speed and sky high with two low budget
features in 2007 on broadway and awaken
the dead after that he spent much of his
time acting in some of the most popular
shows of the decade such as csi friday
night lights and community harris's pace
has never slowed down while continuing
to make guest appearances on a variety
of shows throughout the 2010s he's also
lent his talents to the films in time
and sharon123 he's had a busy 2021 he
made a guest appearance on abc's the
rookie and he took part in the crime
drama no man of god and the horror film
shot in the dark
mary elizabeth winstead who played gwen
in sky high is probably the film's most
recognizable cast member that isn't kurt
russell
though she began her acting career in
1997 sky high was only winstead's third
feature film her role in the film gave
winstead the opportunity to display her
range from kind-hearted classmate to
diabolical villain winstead followed up
sky high with final destination 3 and
horror has been part of her wheelhouse
ever since
she's made appearances in abraham
lincoln vampire hunter and 10
cloverfield lane as well as iconic pop
culture films like scott pilgrim vs the
world and birds of prey winstead's most
recent leading role was as the titular
assassin in the netflix action film kate
while speaking with collider about the
movie winstead took a moment to reflect
on her beloved performance in sky high
and speculated about what role her
character would take in a sequel film
saying
gwen is still operating as a super
villain for sure i went through puberty
twice
for this
kevin heffernan had already starred in
super troopers by the time he got a part
in sky high and he put his comedic
experience to excellent use by bringing
school bus driver ron wilson's unabashed
excitement to life just like the
audience watching sky high ron is an
enthusiastic fan of all things superhero
getting to drive the next generation of
heroes to sky high every morning is a
dream come true for ron and by the end
of the film he gets his own opportunity
to be a hero in the years since sky high
kevin heffernan has continued putting
his talents to work in comedies of all
stripes
he's made guest appearances in some of
the biggest sitcoms of the past two
decades curb your enthusiasm how i met
your mother and veep to name a few and
his film roles which include strange
wilderness and the baby makers have had
a similarly comedic bend currently fans
can catch up with heffernan on truetv's
tacoma fd he created the series with the
help of steve lemmy and the two of them
lead the show as chief terry mcconkey
and captain eddie panisi
as one of the few adults cast and sky
high jim rash already had over a decade
of acting experience under his belt when
he signed on to play mr grayson and his
alter ego stitches
most notably from 2002 through 2006 he
had a recurring role as fenton on that
70s show
though he'd maintained a steady stream
of roles up to that point rash's career
was in many ways just getting started
four years after sky high rash joined
the cast of community as dean craig
pelton a role that he would continue
playing throughout the show's entire six
season run he's also made non-stop
appearances in tv shows and movies for
the past decade most recently he's been
the voice of flicks in star wars
resistance and the riddler in the
animated harley quinn series rash is
also the only member of the sky high
cast to have won an academy award so far
having received the best adapted
screenplay oscar for the descendants in
2012.
dave foley is probably best known for
the work he did before sky high foley
and kevin mcdonald formed sketch comedy
troop the kids in the hall in 1984 and
their tv show of the same name ran from
1988 to 1995. the kids in the hall is
set for a revival in 2022 but foley has
kept himself plenty busy in the years
since it went off the air in addition to
starring in the occasional feature film
foley has spent a majority of his time
making guest appearances on everyone's
favorite tv shows he's taken on live
action series like it's always sunny in
philadelphia and veep as well as
animated shows like robot chicken and
dan vs in 2021 alone foley has made
guest appearances in young sheldon call
your mother superstore and the morning
show there isn't a style of comedy that
foley can't seem to handle perfectly
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite stars are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]